[Music]
each ingredient goes into an
industrial-sized mixer starting with
white sugar then brown sugar then butter
[Music]
the mixer thoroughly blends these first
ingredients until the butter becomes
soft and creamy and the sugars are
evenly dispersed then it's time for the
headliner chocolate chips next flour
followed by baking soda to make the
dough rise and salt to add flavor the
final ingredients are whole eggs beaten
combined with vanilla made from beans
harvested in Madagascar Africa mixing
resumes until everything's well blended
which usually takes about five minutes
workers transfer the cookie dough to a
machine called the former it pushes the
dough through round eyes producing row
upon row of round pieces weighing 41
grams each one of several sizes the
factory produces the factory then flash
freezes the dough rounds for sale to
foodservice customers such as
restaurants and hotels which bake the
cookies in their own kitchens the freeze
tunnel uses liquid nitrogen to create
the frigid temperature the passing dough
rounds solidify in approximately five
minutes exiting the freeze tunnel the
dough rounds pass under a metal detector
to ensure they don't contain any metal
particles the packaging system is
entirely automated the first station
corrects the box the second station
lines it with plastic
a conveyor belt meanwhile feeds the
frozen unbaked cookies onto automated
scales once a scale hits the per box
weight
feeding pauses the bottom swings open
and the cookies drop into the box now
waiting directly underneath the next
stations seal and label the boxes which
workers then load onto pallets the
pallets go into a storage freezer where
they stay until it's time to ship them
out by freezer truck to the customer